so um welcome everyone uh i'm over here
in the uk so uh i can say good morning
you know
most i guess in the uk in the uh
somewhere in europe but probably further
afield so
uh good morning good afternoon good
evening wherever you are my name's robin
moffat
um i'm a developer advocate at
confluence that's confluent the people
who
work on patrick kafka not who build
wikis
um my background is in data and
analytics and data warehousing and
building systems
around that and i've been working with
kafka for the last few years now
um i do lots of blogging i do lots of
talking even with
lockdown i've started doing a few
youtube videos so you can go to those
links at the bottom there
and go and find out more about this
stuff i do lots of twitters
my handle is on every single slide
because i'm shameless like that
so if you enjoy the talk if you have
questions if you have any feedback
then do send me a tweet and let me know
today i'd like to talk all about apache
kafka
and apache kafka is this concept of an
ecosystem on a platform
so this is not a deep dive into apache
kafka and they're like the nuts and
bolts of all kind of
individual pieces this is kind of like
kafka 101
if you like like an overview of what is
kafka
what are the pieces that make it up to
hopefully set you up with a very solid
foundation to understand what it is
and how you can use it and hopefully how
it will benefit you in your projects
kafka itself is built on this concept of
events so events are these fantastic
things that are really really useful
because events comprise two specific
things
events are a notification that something
has happened
and they're also a state that goes with
that notification
so if you think about a lot of the data
that you work with day-to-day in your
systems whatever it is you're building
whatever domain
you work in a lot of the data you work
with started life
as an event so people think of kafka as
like this streaming thing and
they'll have this mental idea of like
here is this stream of things and then
over there the majority of the world is
like this other just like static data
but if you stop and think about how that
static data was born
it probably started life as an event and
many many different things
are events you have human generated
events you have people
interacting with our businesses you have
people buying things or
clicking on our websites you have
inventory moving around between your
warehouses
these are events there's a notification
someone bought something
and there's state what was it that was
bought what was the item where was the
shop what time was it
you've got a event of things moving in
our warehouses
the notification something moved the
state what was it where did it move from
where did it move to it's not just human
generated events
machines generate events as well you
have iot devices
with all the different readings being
sent out you have networks switches and
routers and firewalls
huge number of events happening in those
and you also have the applications
themselves that we're building
you write an application you have some
error handling code and you say we're
going to hit this thing here because
there's a problem that is an event
there was a problem there's your
notification and then you've got the
state you've got the stack trace
here's the particular problem we hit
here's the error message here's the
stack trace
and so applications we're like they'll
probably chuck out a message to a log
file
but those things that we're chucking
into a log file are events
so events if we stop and think about it
are pretty much
everywhere and there are a few
exceptions but most data that we work
with starts life
as an event and then like the
implementation detail of how we store it
is how a lot of us then think about data
oh well my data sits in a database it's
not an event
well it actually is it's just you've
decided to store it
in a different way like aggregated it up
away from the events but it started life
as in events and these events are very
very powerful
there's a lot of good stuff around like
event driven systems and event sourcing
because people realize that if you have
events you can rebuild state
you can drive systems in an asynchronous
loosely coupled way by saying
if something happens over here this
thing needs to respond
but we're not going to tightly couple
them together we're going to start
pulling this thing to say have you done
it yet
we're gonna do it the other way around
we're gonna say this thing happens now
other people
cannot know about it so events
are really powerful but how are we gonna
actually use them
or as the buzzword would say how we're
going to leverage them but we may use
how we're going to take advantage of
these fantastically powerful things
we need a platform on which to build
with them
so we're going to start small we're
going to start with
an event but obviously events happen
continually over time so now we've got
lots of events so we need to think about
how we're going to capture these events
how we're going to work with them
and for the moment we're going to think
of an event simply as a key value pair
we're going to drill into this concept a
bit later on in this talk but for now
just bear with me we're just going to
think of an event
as a key value and this could be an
order being placed it could be your
application throwing an error
it could be a temperature reading from a
device it's just an event
so we saw logs in this very very simple
but very powerful
idea of a blog this log is not your
application log file that's like log.txt
means log4d or whatever i
i suppose that is a log but a log that
i'm talking about here is a much more
foundational fundamental concept
which is where we say this log is where
we put
our events and we append them as they
happen
over time so something happens we write
it onto the login it's append
only it's append only and it is
immutable so because it's immutable
that's very very powerful
because we can say here are the things
that happened and we know
that none of them have changed so if you
imagine having a conversation with
someone and you say things and someone
else
says something and maybe you get into an
argument and you say some heated things
that
you probably wish you hadn't said with
hindsight but you've said them
it is immutable that event has happened
that fact has been said that
sentence was said in anger and you can't
go back and change that it is
immutable all you can do is like
hopefully put down another event to try
and counteract that and apologize and
undo what you said but it has been said
it is immutable
and so is a log so a log is like a
commit log of all the things that have
happened
of our events so events happen over time
and it gives us this idea
of the log so the log is what underpins
everything
that we're doing here so it's a very
simple but a very powerful concept
so if we think of this idea of taking
all these events that are happening we
store them on a log
at some point we're going to say well
that's not necessarily manageable
just have like one log with all these
different types of events going on
because we've got lots of different
types of events we've got lots of
different entities
so we say well okay let's take this log
and we're going to carve it up and we'll
call it topics
topics is a fairly well-known term if
you're from the database world like i am
you probably think in terms of tables
but here we've got things like clips on
our website
so people are clicking our around our
website those are events there's a
notification they did a click
the state what was it they clicked on
who was the user what's their user agent
and so on
we've got orders coming in so someone
placed an order there's our notification
or the order shipped there's a
notification here's the state around it
we've got another example topic here
called customers
and people don't always realize this
first off they'll kind of think well
clicks and orders those are obvious
events and i can kind of easily see how
those would go on to a topic and
store those in an event platform but
customers
customers are like what would call
reference data or lookup data
and does it make sense to put those into
a series of events
but if you think about it customers or
any kind of data like that are created
through an event it gets created there's
your event
and it gets updated and it gets updated
again and so a customer registers on our
website there's your create and the
state that goes with it
they move house they update their
address there's your events in the state
that goes with it and if you capture all
of those different events to do with
your customers
or your product reference or whatever
you end up with a series of events that
you can replay to give you the state
of that particular entity so in
data warehousing analytics we talk about
facts and dimensions
and it's the same kind of thing here all
of these things live
very very naturally when broken down
into events
because with all of these things we can
replay them to rebuild state
when we want to so we cut up our log
into what we call topics and this gives
us the ability to arrange our data into
kind of separate entities to make it
appropriate for use we're going to cut
it up
one third time and we're going to do
this as a way of giving us a system
which is highly scalable and performance
so each topic can have one or more
partition
so partitions take that topic and they
cut it up
and they say well within this topic
we're going to have maybe three
different partitions
and the reason for doing this is that we
can then spread that data
across different nodes because kafka
itself is a distributed system
we'll talk about that in just a moment
so we can distribute the data
across different ones by having separate
partitions
but you can also use it for
parallelization of reading and
processing that data
so instead of just having like one log
log file you can only read through
sequentially by one user
instead we split up into topics and
partitions within those topics
and now we can process that data at very
very high scale
so we started talking about getting data
in we've started talking about getting
data out
so let's talk about this concept of pub
sub
first off publishing the data to the
topic how do we get that data how do we
get these events
into a topic we use the producer api
so apache kafka it ships with a java
client and there's
other client libraries for c c plus plus
python.net go and
like every single common language there
is if there isn't one for your language
of choice or you'd rather not use that
there's also a rest api
you can also use for producing data so
whatever it is you're using
there's always a way to get data onto a
kafka topic
as we said the data goes on to the end
of the topic when we produce it as
events get
appended to the end of it if we're
talking about using a producer that's
going to write across different
partitions
it will handle allocating those
different partitions
the producer codes look something like
this if you're using java which they're
going to spin up and produce
we're going to connect to a broker i'm
going to send messages
in this particular way
so the beginning i talked about events
and i said for now let's just talk about
events as these key values
now let's drill into a little bit more
about what we mean about
that because kafka itself just treats
those messages
as key value bytes it just says you've
got a key part of the message
and you've got a value and that could be
like foo and bar as your key and your
value
it could be your key is one your value
is a hugely complex schema
like a tweet is a good example of an
event it's got a key which might be the
tweet id
and then the value of a tweet it's like
if you've used the developer api you'll
see
like a hugely nested structure like all
sorts of stuff so the value itself isn't
just like
one single volume the value itself could
be hugely complex nested if you want to
you don't even have to specify the key
and if you don't specify a key
when we use the producer api it will
just round robin
those messages evenly across however
many partitions you've got in your topic
so you end up with a nice even
distribution but
within partitions we have this guarantee
of ordering
so when you write data into a partition
you're guaranteed by kafka by
the way it's built that when you read
that data back
you'll get it in the strict order that
has written to that partition
which is really really useful because
we've got this immutability guarantee
that stuff's not going to be changed
once it's being written to it
we've also got this stripped ordering
guarantee which means we can say well
i'm going to take this particular
instance of an entity like a particular
customer
i'm going to read back all the events
that we've got relating to that customer
or this order or whatever
i know i'll get every single one and
it's not being changed along the way
because it's immutable
and i know that i'll get every single
one in all
but that only applies within a partition
so if we're doing that kind of thing we
need to make sure that we've got
all of the data relating to our
particular
instance of an entity that we're
interested in on the same partition
and that's where keys come in because if
we don't set a key the data just gets
round rubbing evenly distributed across
the partitions which might be fine
but you might actually want to ensure
that we do have that locality and the
partition for each instance
so for that we set a key and then kafka
producer api uses a hash
of that key to make sure that every key
value
ends up on the same partition every time
it gets written to
so you then end up with the data spread
across the partitions
and this is where choosing your key
appropriately comes in
because you want to make sure you set it
based on i want all of these events to
be strictly in order
for a particular customer or something
but you also want to make sure you don't
end up with lumpy distribution
so if you said i'm going to partition it
i'm going to use the key of
location that might not be so good
because you're going to end up with like
one partition that's hugely
overpopulated maybe if you break it down
by city like the capital city will have
loads of records
and like really small uh low and
populated uh areas
will have much fewer records in their
partitions so you need to pick it
appropriately as well for
bearing in mind how you're going to
spread that data out
so this producer api it's a client
library it's an application that we
write
it gets the messages onto the topic it
handles talking to the brokers it
handles the partition logic
there's various different languages
there's a rest api as well if you want
to use that
so we've got the data onto a topic how
do we get the data out
and this is a little bit more
complicated for good reasons because
it's very very powerful
but producing data onto kafka is
basically like where's my kafka cluster
and here's the data off you go we're
going to talk about serialization later
that's where it gets a little bit more
interesting
but for now producing data check the
data and we're done
consuming the data it's really
interesting it's very very powerful what
we can do here
when we go to kafka and say i would like
to read a message that access is
only sequential you can't do like random
access and get like give me the value
for all of these particular
keys or like do searches on it like we
would do in a database it doesn't work
like that
we've got a log we've got this immutable
append only log
and we can seek through that log to a
particular place in it and then start
scanning through
and reading those messages so our first
consumer comes along and they connect to
calculus and i'd like the messages from
the orders topic
and kafka says okay here are all of
those messages
now if you're thinking of kafka in your
little
mind model of technologies that we've
got to try and comprehend these days
like all these different terms and stuff
like that
if you've got kafka bucketed in that
same area as
transient message cues then you need to
scratch that
and like reevaluate because kafka is
actually an event streaming platform in
its own right
it's not transient message queue that's
one of the most important things to
understand
it's a distributed commit log that we
can send messages to
and we can read messages from but when
we read a message
it is not deleted even if another
consumer comes along and says
i'd also like to read those messages
kafka doesn't say oh well two consumers
have read that so i must be done with
them i'm going to delete it now
kafka says you gave me that data i
appended it to the log
it will stay on that log until you tell
me
to get rid of it so regardless of what
the consumers have done
we say to kafka this particular topic
here it's got information about clicks
for the website i'd like to keep seven
days worth of that because that's kind
of the the business
use case for processing that data this
topic of orders
i'd like to keep that for 10 years
please because that's when we're going
to need to use it
this topic of customers over here we're
going to keep that forever
because we want to have that as our
system of record for all of our
customers you know when they're created
updated
we can use that and we can replay it to
build the state anywhere else we want to
but we're going to keep it forever so
when the consumers come along they
simply say to kafka i would like to
re-date it from this topic
and kafka will either say okay here's
every single new messages
as it arrives or it'll go back to the
beginning of the topic and say
here is every message that i've stored
and scan through and hear
all of those and then hear the new
messages as they arrive as well
consumers can even say well i've read
those ones from here
and actually i'd like to replay them so
my application was running everything
was good
and then downstream of my application
something went bad
we realized there was a bug in the code
i would like to rewind
i would like to skip back to a
particular offset so let's go back to
offset 42
or i would like to go to an offset based
on timestamp i would like to start
reading messages
as of yesterday at three o'clock kafka
says okay that corresponds to this
offset
here you go here are the messages since
yesterday at three o'clock and then we
keep on scanning through
until we get to the end of the log and
then the consumer keeps on reading those
new messages as they arrive so when a
consumer reads a message it is not
deleted consumers don't even have to
exist they don't even have to be in the
thought of yet
when we write data to kafka and this is
one of the very very powerful things
because we can then say i subscribe to
this one i don't subscribe to silly
turns
i agree with this idea of events being
very very useful and very very powerful
so i'm going to embrace this and my
application or my system is going to say
something happened someone clicked on
something someone bought something
i'm going to produce that event to kafka
because that's probably going to be
something that someone else
wants to know about and that's all the
producing application has to do
and now your consumers can come along
and either they were built for
specifically for that particular use
case and
it gets produced and then they consume
or it could be a consumer comes along
next week
or next next month or next year and says
oh we've got a topic of orders that's
really useful
i'm going to go and read those so long
as we've set the retention appropriately
on the topic
anyone with the appropriate security
setup can then come and read those
messages so consumer
again here's the java example connect to
the broker we call the broker
particular topic and we receive those
messages
so a consumer will read data from the
topic
or read across multiple partitions if
the topic is partitioned
we can have separate consumers which are
completely independent from each other
again it's worth pointing out because
kafka is storing this data
if one consumer like falls over and like
hasn't read some stuff the other one is
not affected
that data stays there as long as we've
told it to retain it
and then it gets aged out so other
consumers aren't going to suffer
if one of them has stopped like in other
systems things would start to back up
and like you'd end up with these huge
bottlenecks because one of them hadn't
read the messages and
the system couldn't cope with all these
messages building up students
kafka works completely differently from
that
kafka also lets you consume messages in
parallel
and this is where the partitioning thing
comes in because at the moment on the
screen here we've got two consumers c1
c2 the blue one at the top the green one
at the bottom separate completely
independent applications
each one reads all of the data in the
topic
what if we need to process that data
faster that a single consumer can keep
up with
so c1 the blue one at the top of the
screen here maybe that's some kind of
fraud processing thing that
as orders get placed on this source
topic it needs to process them it needs
to score them
write them back on to a separate topic
but another system to pick up and
do something with and we've got a single
instance of that application
and it can't keep up with the throughput
that we need to meet our sla for this
particular service that we've written
and we scale the machine and we put more
cpus in and give it more memory and
we still can't keep up she's okay well
let's scale it out
let's add in additional instances of
that consumer
so now we've still got two logical
consumers got c2 at the bottom got c1 at
the top
but c1 has got multiple physical
instances
of the consumer and kafka handles this
for you you simply say here is another
instance of my consumer
and kafka's got this protocol as part of
it so
a nice little slide here for my
colleague vic gamov the idea is you've
got your consumers their little birds in
the nest cheaping away
that nest forms what's called a consumer
group so consumer group
is this logical grouping of a set of
instances of the consumer
doing the same logical task and then
kafka itself acts as mummy burn
it's like it's called the consumer group
coordinator this is okay
you're an instance of this consumer
group you get data from this partition
you're another instance of a consumer
within this consumer group
you get data from this partition so you
end up with a data
allocated across based on the number of
partitions that you've got
the number of consumers that you've got
and it will evenly distribute that work
so if we've got four partitions and
we've got four consumers then each
consumer
within that consumer group gets data
from one partition
if we had four partitions and two
consumers within the consumer group
each consumer would get two partitions
and kafka understands that you've got
these processes running within that
consumer group it'll keep an eye on them
and if you lose one of them
then it'll say okay well we've now got a
partition that's not being consumed
it's not being read from and we don't
want to do that need because we've got
guarantees in place that
all of this data is going to get read so
then we say well okay one of the other
consumers
will get allocated work from that
partition
so kafka does all of the heavy lifting
here for you that within your
application you may have to do otherwise
start writing like how do i manage
scaling the consumption of this workload
and all of these tricky things
you simply say here's my consumer it's
part of this consumer group
kafka says okay you get this you get
that
so consumer api very very powerful a
little bit more complicated than the
producer api
it's still a client application and it
reads the messages from the topics
it lets you scale your work horizontally
you just add in
additional consumers and again different
uh libraries as well
we need somewhere to store all of this
data and we're going to store it on
brokers so so far we've been very very
abstract we've talked about logs and
events there's like these key value
things now we're getting out into the
nitty-gritty of like where does this
stuff even live like
i'm gonna go and try this out it sounds
brilliant but where to even live what
process do i need to run
kafka itself has a broker process that's
like a jvm process that you spin up and
you can see on your machine
so the kafka broker is where this
actually all happens
and it's a distributed system you can
run a single instance of it if you want
but that's not really distributed it's
not very scalable it's only fault
tolerance
so a typical production deployment will
start off with a minimum
of three brokers and each broker
will contain some of the data which is
why we partition it because we can then
spread
out across those different brokers you
don't have to partition it
but then you'll see from the previous
example you're not going to scale
very far with it so each
holds some of the data you've got four
partitions those partitions are going to
get spread
across each broker and standard
distributed systems
fashion we're going to hold redundant
copies of that data too
so we've got the leader partition exists
on the different brokers
and then you've got follower copies of
that partition data
all for redundancy spread across the
brokers as well
so here we've got three brokers we've
got a kind of like replication factor of
three so it exists on three different
brokers
if you had seven brokers you're some
without data from some of those
partitions it just means you've got that
room to scale if you want to and if you
have other topics then
their data will be spread out across
them so the
example here is a single topic with four
partitions
spread across those three brokers and if
you lose a broker
if things go bang or someone unplugs it
from the wall or something like that
because we have redundant copies of the
data one of the remaining brokers can
step up and say well that's fine
i will take over leader responsibilities
for this particular partition
so it's very very powerful it means that
you can scale out as you need to
and you have this built-in redundancy
and failover
provided by default
so let's actually have a look at this in
practice i'll show you a very simple
demo
and then we're going to talk about uh
more advanced things that you can do
with it
so the example i'm going to show you
here and all the slides i should have
said all of the slides and stuff they'll
be online
and follow my twitter i'll be tweeting
them or i'll put them on the slack
channel afterwards as well
but all the demos are online as well so
you can actually go and try this out for
yourself it's just based around
docker and docker compose so there's a
cheat sheet which is when i keep on
looking down like that that's what i'm
looking at
and you can follow the demo through and
try it out so the first thing that we're
going to do
is we're going to fill up a producer and
here i'm using a command line interface
uh called kafka cat
um i'm more of a kind of data engineer
type person than like a full-on coder
and so i tend to kind of like the the
command line instead of writing
applications
but if you prefer using java or
something like that you could go and
imagine your java code here or python or
whatever
it's a producer api okay so it's a tool
called kafka cat
it's going to connect to kafka broker
and we're going to produce messages
to this topic called test
so we hit enter and then we worry
because it's a live demo and nothing's
happening but it's a producer it's
saying well give me some data to produce
so i've said here dash k colon because
we're going to use colon as a separator
between keys
and values so let's send a message
there's a key called one i'm going to
say
hello ndc and
we've sent two messages to kafka we've
sent them to the topic
so now we can read them from the topic
so i'm now going to spin up
a second process so in the bottom of the
screen here we're going to create
ourselves a consumer so pretty much the
same command here's my broker
here's my topic and then dash c because
you want a consumer
this is there's our two messages hello
in dc
you'll notice there it's just showing
the values of those messages not the
keys as well because that's what it does
by default
and if we say some more send some more
messages so like i
wish i was in oslo
you can see those messages coming across
as we send them to
the producer they get consumed they get
consumed
but they don't get deleted super
important point and the reason i labor
it's like if you're familiar with kafka
apologies for going on about it
if you're not familiar to captain with
kafka it's a really really important
point to get so i'm going to keep on
laboring that point because we've
consumed the messages
does not mean anything to do with when
they're going to get deleted from the
topic they're completely
decoupled concepts they'll stay on the
topic for as long as we've told kafka to
keep the data on that topic file
so we can read the data again so in the
bottom right of the screen here again we
use kafka cards
we're going to use a consumer and this
time we're going to use this here which
basically says
format the data as it comes out so it's
going to read the messages and it's
going to say okay we've got data from
the test topic it's from this particular
partition
here are the offsets of those individual
messages
again we can see we've got the values
and you've got the key
so you've got the key to the messages
which is also being displayed
and if we send some more messages now so
like this one doesn't have a key
so we send a new message there it
doesn't have to have a key you send that
across and both the consumers read
get that message straight away and you
can see down here
where we're showing the key it has a
blank because we don't have a key
i can send more messages you can see it
as we send those messages they're going
straight across to those constraints
if we go to the consumer here and clear
that so we can see what's going on
we can also say well i would like to
read instead of from the beginning
of the topic just start at this
particular asset just start
offset six so we know that we got to
offset five last time
we've decided that we weren't so sorry
we got to offset uh 10
last time and now we want to reprocess
so it's okay we're going to go back to
offset six
this is okay here's the messages from
offset six onwards
in saying that i realize i've admitted
in a very very important detail
which is that as consumer applications
it's not our responsibility to track the
offset
kafka tracks the offset for you so as a
consumer you read the messages and say
yeah i've processed those messages
kafka stores the offset for each
consumer
so when our consumer reconnects kafka
says okay this is where you got to be
last time
and off you go and as a consuming
application you can optionally say
never mind that i would actually like to
start from this point here
that kafka tracks those assets for you
it's a really important point to me
we've got the producer we're sending
nonsense over to a topic we're reading
nonsense from that topic it's just key
value bytes remember
so i could send some json over here so
you can say like here's this message
i'm gonna type in some json it's like
the most simple um
json message in the world so we send
that over you can see you've got the
value picked up down here
over on the right hand side you've got
the key value but we're just sending
bytes to the kafka topic
because actually we need to think about
serialization we're going to talk about
that
in just a moment what i'm going to talk
about next though
is now that we've got this concept of a
producer and consumer
why are you going to unbeld with us and
what are the things that we're not going
to build with it
so let's head back to the slides so i
can see a few questions coming in and
that's brilliant
if i get chance at the end i will take
the questions from here
um if you want to i would suggest copy
and paste them into the slack channel
because then i can answer asynchronously
as all good systems should
and i can actually go through those and
make sure i get to them um as i say if
we get time i'll do them
on webex as well but feel free to put
them onto the slack
um i'm off on the slack if you want to
attack me about track 7
room as well um so we can do them there
so
that was a brief demo as i say the code
is online i'll share the link
afterwards produce data consume data
consume data
multiple times consume data reconsume
data
that's what kafka lets you do and it's
all pretty good
it's a very very powerful it's very
scalable system
but we've only just really got started
or put it another way
i've not even finished yet because the
data that we're getting in and the data
that we're getting out
you start to see the same kind of
patterns that people adopt and want to
do with us
because they say i've got a kafka i've
heard this kafka thing is good i'm going
to kafka all the things
and now that i've got this kafka i would
like to have lots of things
i would like to get some data from my
database into kafka
because i want to drive an application
with it or i've got data in my kafka
and i would like to push that down
somewhere else i'd like to send it to s3
i'd like to say ha kafka stores my data
for me as well as sending it to s3 i'd
also like to send it
to hdfs or to any number of other places
also one says well you know that kind of
like big ball hairy monolith
that we've got that's underpinned by a
database we need to replace that it's
kind of like kind of sucks and it's like
it's old or
it was written by someone else we didn't
change it because it's all like this
messy thing
we'd like to move or we'd like to evolve
so much more flexible architecture we're
going to go to the microservices route
and
we would like to take what's happening
in that existing application
and use it to drive our new application
we're not going to go big bang
because we know how those kind of
projects usually end up would simply
like to say when
stuff happens in our existing
application
we would like to use those events to
drive our new one
and if you think about events and what
they are events actually live in
databases as well
so we've got our existing monolith and
it's using a database so it's an
e-commerce system every time someone
creates an order or updates a customer
does something
it writes it to the database and in the
database we've got order tables and
customer table all this kind of stuff
but the database itself is built on a
append only distributed
um this app end only commit log it's
distributed maybe
but we can take those events that happen
in the database and we can capture them
and we can stream them into kafka and
because we can stream them into kafka we
can build
new applications driven by events in
kafka
populated by stuff happening in the
database and now we can start to chip
away at what's happening in our existing
application
we say well when this new order gets
created
we're gonna uh run some order processing
like a fraud detection thing or
something
over in our new application driven by
those events from the source one so to
migrate over time bits and pieces of
functionality
whilst the existing one is still running
but whatever it's for building whether
we're starting to migrate things whether
building pipelines from like databases
to s3 or whatever
we're going to have to get data between
these systems we're gonna have to get
data from the database into kafka
from kafka to s3 and people will
probably say well we've got a producer
api
we've got a consumer api i shall write
myself a program
and i'll go to the database and i'll
pull the database and i'll kind of pull
those messages in
and then i realize i can't keep up with
a single um instance doing it so i'll
have to scale out
i'll have to work out how i distribute
that workload across having scaled it
out
and i've solved that and now i need to
make sure if one of them dies another
one can pick up because it's tracked
where it's got to and track the offsets
and then we also want to use the same
thing to be able to pull in data from
other
sources like message queues or flat
files and we also want to push data down
to
target systems so why don't we make this
thing kind of like modular and we can
like
we can make a framework we can save the
business like we're going to solve all
your problems we're going to build
a framework and this sounds like a lot
of fun to do
but it's a trap because building
frameworks is a whole bunch of fun
but it doesn't differentiate our
business from any other just because
we've learned how to write data from
cathode to s3
that's what everyone's doing that's us
being able to do that doesn't bring us
forward beyond the competition
and also sorry to say it's a lot of fun
to build these frameworks
but the fun has been had for you apache
kafka includes its own
framework for integrating other systems
into kafka and it's called kafka connect
so kafka connect is the integration api
if you like for apache castle
and it lets you stream data from systems
into kafka
from kafka down to other systems and it
means that you can do all of this
integration
and you can do all of this integration
from databases and message queues and
flat files down to data stores and sql
and
cloud object stores and wherever you
want to get and put your data
as a either just like flowing through
kafka as a pipeline
or driving applications in kafka or
taking the results of applications
produced into kafka
down to other places for analytics you
can do all of this
and it's driven by configuration you
simply say here's my json it declares
where about my data from where i'd like
to put my data which topics and so on
and off we go and kafka connect is
pluggable
so you can say i've got my connectors
which talk to particular technologies
i've got my converters which handle
serialization which i promise we're just
about to get onto
you can even do transformation work on
the messages as they pass through this
pipeline
you can say i'm going to ingest from the
database but i'd like to drop out these
particular fields
before we even send them to kafka i've
got these fields here i'd like to change
their data types i'd like to change the
schema
you can do this as it passes into kafka
or for a sync connector
as you take it from kafka and write it
down stream
you can go to confluence hub to download
all of these different connectors and
converters
just search for your particular
technology and do a command line install
or
click on it to do the installation and
off you go
to run kafka connect it's just a jvm
process
it doesn't run on your brokers so on
your broker machine that's like where
your broker runs and you'll have
separate broker machines
kafka connect runs separately unless you
like prototyping in which case it all
runs on your laptop anyway
but for an idea of how you deploy it
kafka connect
runs separately it's a jvm process
within which the different connector
tasks run
and you can scale it out so kafka
connects
under the covers it's using producer
consumer apis so it can also benefit
from kafka's ability to scale and have
fault tolerance and
reallocate work as it needs and if you
lose a worker you scale this out it's
fault tolerance
you can bring the work or have to
connect or bring that work back into a
place
where it can run if you lose a worker
so kafka connects is this integration
api for apache kafka
got a whole bunch of different
connectors that you can plug into it
but we now need to think and finally
address this point
of serialization because i started off
this talk
by saying well let's like wave our hands
a little bit and just pretend that like
events are key values okay like we'll
brush the rest of that detail into the
carpet
now is the time to pull back that carpet
and i actually examine
what's going on here what is a key value
message what are we actually doing with
us
well key value bites are what we sent to
kafka and as developers
our software engineers as whatever our
job title is today we need to work out
how we're going to serialize it
if we're reading the data we need to
know how we're going to deserialize it
and hopefully we don't just play any
meaning
between one of these different terms and
pick the one that's got the sharpest
abbreviation because that'd be a
terrible idea
we need to understand what are our
options for serialization
what are the implications of picking the
different ones and this
is where schemas come in because schemas
and serialization
are very much intertwined take a step
back for a moment
think about how services without kafka
as dreadful as it sounds
how services communicate when they're
synchronously coupled
one service says i'm going to send this
data to you and the other server says
i'm expecting to receive
that data from you and i'm expecting to
have these fields in it and these types
in it and
these values and so on and so schemers
have a sorry
services have a contract between them
and this contract is their api
and it says this is what i will send
this is what you'll send this is what
i'll send you this is what i'll expect
to receive
and you don't have to do this
synchronously without rest or
jrpc or whatever you're going to use you
could use an event
you could say actually we'll use kafka
to kind of
asynchronously couple our services
together so instead of saying
i will send you this i'll wait for you
to send me something back you say
okay someone came to our website and
they created a profile or they updated
their profile
so i'll put that event onto a topic and
i'll put that
onto the queue another service says well
that's good
i will read that we can start acting
asynchronously because they don't have
to be
tightly coupled together so we get a
bunch of benefits from making that more
loosely coupled
so we've got topics um as the way of
transferring that data between them
so we've got websites and it's um
insurance websites so someone updates
their profile and the quote service
takes that update and it does some
scoring it puts it back onto another
topic
for a profile service to receive but the
way
that happens with kafka almost always is
that you'll start off with
an initial use case and always start
with the use case never start with it
just because like it sounds cool when
you heard about it at a conference
always start with a particular use case
that's appropriate for us
but people say well okay we're going to
use asynchronous coupling between these
two services because it makes a lot of
sense
every time someone changes their profile
we'll put that onto a topic
and then our quote service will
subscribe to that topic and it will
receive those updates
but then someone else says oh you've got
a topic with information about customers
every time they change their details
that's really useful because you want to
take that information and we want to
persist that
down into our database we're going to
use that topic as the system our record
and any changes we're going to reflect
that in the database over here
and we're going to take that and do some
stream processing on it over there
and this is the beauty of kafka because
the profile service is doing
absolutely nothing different it's just
continuing to produce events
onto a topic the quote service is doing
nothing different it's just continuing
to read
events off that topic it's just that
other teams can take advantage of that
same
data in a loosely coupled way to come
and say well that data is useful we will
also
use it but now what happens
is that we've got this data that's being
interchanged between these services
and at the moment we're saying like
we've got a user id and it's an integer
we've got an address and it's a voucher
what about some of the other fields what
about time at which the profile change
was made and start off with we use a
bigint and it holds
the number of milliseconds since 1970
since the unix epoch
and the team that came along said we're
going to put this into a database that's
useful okay it looks like it's a number
so we're going to model that
into the database and the stream
processing team saying that's fine it's
a
begin so we're going to process that and
that's fine and everything gets on
nicely
but then the profile service and the
quote service sit down together
they say oh yeah instead of a big end
we're going to use a varchar which is
probably a bad idea for timestamps but
we're gonna do it anyway
we're gonna change so the profile server
says okay that's fine i will now send
across the timestamp as a bad chat
and the quote service like they knew
about this because they sat down
together okay
we're gonna expect that and we're gonna
move fast and we're definitely
going to break things because now we're
sending across what was a big end
as of archer so all of this lovely loose
coupling that we've done
all this benefit that we've got of
building around events now if we're not
careful
we're going to undo all of that because
if we're not careful we start using this
as our message format
and someone says oh yeah serialization
okay all this just like have separated
like what's it really matter i don't
understand the fuss
this is my warning understand that fuss
it really really matters if we eyeball
this
we can see there's an address there's
probably social security
we have no idea what the field names are
we have no idea what the separator
is we can probably guess we have no idea
what the data types are we can probably
guess
and so instead of guessing at it we're
going to do invariably what humans do
which is going to phone up another human
or email them or slack them up
and say what's this field what's this
data type what are these things here
and by the way if you change any of this
please tell me
and because we're an organization and
we're big and we're enterprise we'll
have a change review board
and now instead of moving fast and
breaking things we move really really
slowly we probably still break things
and we tightly couple our systems back
together wouldn't it be great
if there was a different way of doing it
it turns out there is
so instead of playing eenie meenie miney
mo and saying well we've got to
serialize the data kafka's just bites
and i will just like pick one of these
we're going to pick one of these with a
lot of conscious thoughts
we're going to say there's some really
good ways to do it there are some
mediocre ways and there's some fairly
crappy ways
also we're going to use a serialization
method
that has got strong support for schemas
that lets us enforce schema
compatibility guarantees
that let's actually check when we write
data is that going to break things
so we're going to say when the producer
comes in it's going to serialize data
and we're going to use afro we're going
to use protobuf we're going to use json
schema
the schema itself gets stored in
confidence schema registry
the producer can enforce a compatibility
check and make sure that what we're
writing
is compatible with that schema that
we've declared and it puts the data onto
the topic
the consumer comes along not only does
it make short does it say well this is
great because now you're not sending the
random things which is
just going to break me because we've got
compatibility guarantees
the consumer can go to the scheme and
registry and say what's the schema
instead of having to phone someone up
and that person's on holiday and we're
not quite sure who else is managing it
and so on and so on
the consume consumer goes to the scheme
registry which is a computer who doesn't
go on holiday
and it says what's the schema for this
particular message or for this
particular topic
he says well here is the schema and the
consumer laughs and sings with joy
because this is brilliant
because the consumer can now go and do
things and it can say well
i'm a kafka connect consumer i'm going
to take that data i can now go and
declare a database table because i have
the schema and i can go and populate it
i don't have to go back to the people
who produce the data the scheme registry
itself stores its data
within kafka which is pretty cool also
to use it
you use the appropriate serializer
within your producer code
so schemas and schema registry is so so
important
catholic itself is a concept of like we
can do all this scalable fantastic pub
sub and it's persistent and that's great
it's very very powerful but there are
too many examples where people have
started at that and thought this is
great i get kafka now i'm done
see you later guys and i'm off to go and
build this and if you don't have the
other stuff around
it like how let's have some good four
thoughts about serialization about
schemers
you end up having to refactor an awful
lot six months down the line
when you realize the pain that happens
if you don't have strong support for
schemers and what you're doing
i want to finish up with the last piece
of the puzzle within the ecosystem or
the last big piece in the puzzle within
the ecosystem
because these applications that we're
building these consumers that are coming
along and saying this is great we've got
schemas we know how to deserialize the
data
and we can read that data this is happy
days what are we actually doing
with those messages when we read them
we're probably doing
a fairly common set of patterns that can
be distilled down to a few specific
things
i want to give you an example with a
specific set of data instead of just
talking abstract hand-wavy stuff
let's imagine we've got a factory and
we've got robots on that production line
and within those robots we've got lots
of lovely instrumentation and iot type
stuff going on
so every step of the way we're getting
sensor readings with timestamps and all
these different
sorts of values he's a perfect example
of
events on a topic and we're going to
read those events and we're going to do
things with them
but what are we going to do with them
we're going to do a fairly limited set
of things
we're going to do things like saying i
want to read this and i want to filter
it
so read these things in if it matches
this condition go and put it somewhere
else or go and do something
i want to take these things in and i
want to aggregate them i want to count
how many of these things happened
within a particular time frame or i want
to do so to aggregate it
and i want to alert on it so count these
things and
if it's over this amount or take an
average and if it's all this amount
go and do something else or i want to
take these things out to process them
and push them downstream for analytics
or whatever else
these are the kind of things that fit
into a lot of applications that we build
and they're a good example of stream
processing we've got a stream of events
that's been built up over time these
events arrive sequentially over time
and we want to filter it we're going to
process it we're not aggregating we're
going to do stuff to it
we want to say okay we've got a stream
of widgets and widgets have got colors
we would like to fill to that stream of
widgets and we'd like to say i would
create a separate stream of widgets
which are red
any yellow widgets i'm going to ignore
them the red widgets we're going to go
and put onto a separate topic to go on
drive
a special red widget microservice that's
responsible just for doing something to
do with red widgets
that's fine and we can do that and we
can do that using stream processing
there's different ways to do this and
within apache kafka you have a stream
processing library
called kafka streams and kafka streams
is a java api
and you bring it into your java
application that you're writing
and it lets you do stream processing
unless you say take messages from here
filter it for that and go and put it
over there and so it gives you this
framework which means that you don't
have to go and build it
you don't have to go and deploy a
separate set of like stream processing
things over there on
separate technologies so like feeding
water in a separate different way
and make calls out to them you can do
that stream processing
within your application you write a java
application it's responsible for
driving a dashboard or responsible for
servicing user requests
how many things of this thing have
happened recently i'll take this thing
and draw this picture on the thing with
an aggregate of that or a filter of that
you can do that stream processing within
your application that you're building
instead of having to call out to
separate things so instead of just
consumers
we end up with a set of stream
applications and just as you deploy your
applications in a certain way that's
specific and works for you
you test and you deploy your streaming
processing applications
in exactly the same way it's just a java
library that you're bringing in
but not everyone writes java there are
plenty of people using other different
languages or who aren't really coders at
all like me
in which case you say well wouldn't it
be nice if there was a different way to
do stream processing
that you could express in a more
abstract way using a decorative language
like maybe like sql for example
this is where key sql db comes in so key
sql db
is built on top of kafka streams it's
part of confluent platform
and it means that you can use sql to
declare what you'd like to do
with your streams of data i've got a
stream of widgets
i would like to create a new stream a
new kafka topic populated
by these widgets matching this
particular predicate and that's a
proper working example of some k-sql db
code there there's no boiler plate
around it to deploy
you take that and you send it to the
server using the command line interface
using the rest api
and it'll go off and it will run and
it'll continually populate this new
kafka topic
using the statement you've given us so
if we apply this
to the examples i showed you earlier
some of the patterns of what we want to
do with data
we can say well i would like to filter
this particular stream i would like to
know about widgets
that are fall over a certain weight
category so we say we'll select
everything from this stream
where the weight is over 120. so i'd
like to do some counting
i'd like to know how many widgets we've
processed by production line over time
so
that count from here i would like to
take an average of this and we're going
to apply it alerts on it we're going to
have
having uh clause on there so you can do
all of these things using key sql db
and using k sql db you can also take
messages from a stream
and push them down somewhere else using
kafka connect so you've got this
stream of data coming in filter it and
process it and join it if you want to
and then go and put it into s3 or into
aztec search or hdfs or snowflake or
any other of the numerous places that
kafka connect integrates with
so these are examples using k sql db you
can do the exact
uh conceptual thing using kafka streams
but you have to
write it using java which will totally
suit some people
it won't suit others which is why you
have the choice
so i'm going to skip ahead a couple of
slides and i would like to show you
an example of this in action and before
we wrap up
so let's get through my appropriate demo
slide
and then we're going to have a look at
the demo
so in this bit of the demo we're going
to take some data again
i'm going to use kafka cat and this time
using kafka cat to act as a consumer
against a different topic
so this topic has got a much more
sensible set of data in
we've got um instead of just like random
asgf's hitting on the keyboard
we've got a schema we've got users and
we've got information about stock trades
so a buy or a cell and the particular
symbol your account and so on
very common set of data a very common
stream of data and now we want to do
something with it
we want to say i would like to take that
and i would like to filter it for a
particular symbol
and i would like to know how many
transactions have been made for that
particular symbol
in every 15-minute window so we're going
to break it down like that
so we look at this he said well i've got
my stream of data i've got a consumer
i can pull in all those messages and now
i guess i need to start writing some
codes to kind of like work out how to do
that and
we're talking about how many within a
15-minute window so i have to have some
kind of
persistent store to hold that state for
aggregation and what happens if my
application crashes how do i rebuild
that states and stuff
this is where stream processing comes in
so i'm going to show you kc called db
you can do the exact same thing in kafka
streams if you want to
so let's cancel that and let's bring up
the kc called db
prompt so this is kc for db command line
interface
there's also a rest api there's a
graphical api as well
sorry a graphical user interface if
you'd like rather
the first thing we're going to do is
we'll create a stream
on top of this particular topic so
create stream against the kafka topic
called trades
the value for us is avro why are we
using avro why is that such a good thing
because when we create a stream a stream
is just after topic
with a schema where's our schema well
our schema
is here we say describe trades
says that is your schema where does
schema come from the schema came from
the schema registry
this is a perfect example of our schemas
are so very useful
because as a developer as a consumer i
can now take data from that topic
i don't even know who was writing it i
don't have to go and speak to it i can
say i've got data on that topic i've
been granted permission to read from it
i can deserialize it i have the schema i
can now start being productive
i've not had to go and speak to anyone
and say well where's the wiki with this
reference on a blah blah blah blah
i have the data i have the schema and
because i have the schema
i can now start to interrogate the data
i can project columns i can apply
predicates
select everything from this particular
stream where this predicate is not
it says well here are those particular
trades coming through for that
particular symbol
and i could take that i can say okay i'm
going to push that onto a new topic
do this say create stream
for us this is okay i've created that
stream
and that's now populating it with the
results of that select statements
and a stream is just a topic under the
covers with a schema let's say show
topics we've got a new kafka topic
called foo
i could say print through so i'm just
acting as a consumer here
this is well here's your topic called
foo and within that topic called foo
you've just got the values appropriate
to that symbol that we asked for
but we also want to aggregate it we want
to say show me the values
for that just particular symbol
aggregated off over time how many trees
have there been what was the average
value and so on so now we say we're
going to create a table
streams and tables in k sql db and kafka
streams separate concepts i can explain
it another time or go and look at one of
my other talks
i'm going to say we're going to create
uh this particular table it's going to
hold
aggregates the side is whether it's a
buy or sell how many trades what's the
total value what was the average
broken down by a window of every 15
minutes a tumbling window when you have
session windows and hopping windows as
well if you want to
where the symbol is this group by the
slide
we've done that now we can say go and
tell me about this particular table so i
describe that table
it says here's your table here's the
schema for it if we say show topics
we've now got a topic with that data
written
and we can also take that data so let's
actually just check the data out first
so we're going to say
select start from this table
and it says already did that so do that
so now it says for each time window and
it's using the epoch time for the
starting at the end here
here is the total number of trades
here's the average quantity of the trade
is the total
value broken down by time win so we've
got an aggregate there
stored within k sequel db if i had the
rest api to hand i could actually do a
query against that
a key value look up against for this
particular symbol
what's the current uh number of uh units
that have been sold just a key value
lookup like that
but i can also take that i can say i'm
going to push that down
into somewhere like elasticsearch so
here's where kafka connect comes in
instead i'm going to write a bunch of
you saying here's a topic and i'll write
some courage using the consumer api and
elasticsearch api i'm going to push it
down to there you'll see
i'm going to take that i'm going to push
it down to here
and i say sure connectors and make sure
it's running it says
yep it's running so it means we can head
over to
now we use kibana here as the front end
onto elasticsearch
we're going to say have we got any data
in the indexes in the indices it says
yes you have
so we're going to create an index
pattern it says let's do that
i'm going to take the data from this
particular index so if you're not
familiar with elasticsearch it's like a
document.json store
uh very very useful you can use it for
analytics you can use it for search
and cabana is a very nice front end that
goes on top of it
because then once we've declared that
data we can say well show me
the data that you've got in that index
and if we close that
we can say refresh it every second
surely data for the last hour
so now we can see for each time window
so starting at 10 45
so this is this is british summit times
this is an hour uh that from odds lewis
is now a forward of utc
you can see each time window with the
appropriate aggregate in it
and if you start closely at the screen
for this one here the 1131
you'll see those values change it's
refreshing every second and the
data is coming in case sequel db is
taking that stream of data from kafka
it's applying that aggregation and
pushing the results of the aggregation
down to elasticsearch
and it's doing so with a item potent key
so it just updates it
in place it's a very very
quick simple example of what you can do
using
streams of data starting off with simple
key value bytes
applying a schema to it taking it
processing it filtering it aggregating
it
you could do stateful uh lookups against
key values you can push it down into
other systems
to use that data where you want to
so let me finish off um i want to
quick recap and then i'll give you some
resources as well to go and play with us
some more
we'll do questions if time allows others
we'll take it all over to slack
so we started off with this humble
little event
these things that happen all around us
driving our businesses driving our
systems
we said well let's just for now call it
key value bytes because that's what
things are
at the heart we're going to store them
in this log
it's an app end only distributed commit
log we can't go back and change things
within topic partitions they're strictly
ordered which is fantastic
we're going to take this concept of the
log and we're going to build around it
we're going to give people ways of
getting data in and out with the produce
from consumer apis
we've got kafka connect part of apache
kafka we've got kafka streams
part of apache kafka so we've got a full
set of apis you're getting data in and
out
for doing integration we're doing stream
processing with
a conference schema registry we've got
confluent kc sql db
additional pieces of the ecosystem that
let us build these powerful systems
all built around events which you can
like everywhere
and which is so very powerful
hopefully that's whetted you're
interested in kafka if you didn't know
it already
hopefully that's solidified your
understanding of it already if you did
know it
if you want to know more about kafka you
can go and get these books for free
off our website go to the url scan the
qr code
i love logs i heart logs is a great
foundational text for understanding this
idea of a
industry to commit work and why it's so
powerful kafka definitive guide is a
great place to go and like really get
into the wheats with kafka
designing event driven systems again
really good for understanding the
architectural concepts around us
hopefully you want to go and try it out
you can use the demo code that i'm going
to share
afterwards you can also go and use
confluent cloud so this is the only
small little vendor pitch within this
confluent cloud managed kafka manage key
sql db manage kafka connect and stuff
like that
you get 50 off your bill when you sign
up there's a code there you can also use
for an additional
60 there's small print at the bottom
there scan the code go to the url again
i'll post the links afterwards
back to the useful stuff well sorry it's
all useful back to the non-pitchy stuff
uh developer.confluent.io uh is a big
set of resources for learning kafka
so there's blogs there's tutorials
there's podcasts there's videos
the community hangs out on slack so
confident community slack group
go and join it there there's a ton of
different channels for all sorts of
areas i've kafka and confident platform
i'm at i'm off on there there's a ton of
people both confluent engineers a huge
number of community extremely helpful
and welcoming as well
so with that thank you very very much
for your time and these online
conferences
turned out they're kind of pretty good
after all so i'm very grateful to andy
so for inviting me to speak
and i'll head out on that time now so i
won't eat into the next speaker's time
but i will head over to slack now and we
can chat to your heart's content all
about kafka
if you want to hit me up on twitter
instead on at i'm off i'll tweet links
to the slides i'll put links to the
slides also in slack so thank you very
much everyone for your time